the jurgen experience did you go all in
right from the jump when you said all
right i'm going to lose weight
did or did you vacillate did you no once
i you know again
my molar decision and i make it so once
the decision was made
it was more like okay it's out of my
hands i will do what
my trainer says and that's it and that's
been the crazy thing because he'll then
like recently he'll talk about other
clients and he'll be like oh you know
you wanted him to do this he didn't want
to do it so he didn't do it and i go oh
i i never comprehended that i could tell
you no
you know like i never even thought that
i could be like yeah i know i'm tired
[ __ ] it
you know i thought oh i'm paying you
this is your job
so i just listen to you you know and
but i think you know so that way it's
just me having a good attitude about it
i
i don't once i was in it i was in it and
then later came to think of like oh i
have to mentally now
undo like the fact that i still
want these things you know i it was
easier to just say okay well i'm not
doing it because i need to protect my
health and i'm going to die but once
i got down to a healthy way it was like
okay
now we have to deal with the mental
aspect i went to like overeaters
anonymous for a couple of classes and i
didn't like that
what is that like it's like alcoholics
anonymous basically but it's the same
book even that they read
from yeah so i think they just need to
get their [ __ ] changed and get their
[ __ ] together because
it doesn't match up because they read
you these like things like oh
reached my lowest moment i lost my
family i was living in a train
and i was like well no i can't relate to
that my lowest moment is that i
you know took a bite of a doughnut and
then put it on top of the trash and then
came back and got it and then had to put
it deeper in the trash
that's what i need to work on yeah
it's a different kind of addiction right
mm-hmm yeah
though you don't really lose your life
the same way you don't you know
junkie it's slow you lose your life in a
weird way you lose your physical life
yeah you start telling i just remember
mentally the change of being like well
you know i just don't want to do that i
don't want to
i can't physically go scuba diving they
won't let me at my way so you know i'm
just not
interested in any of that you know and
now she's like i want to do anything i
went to you know with the pro wrestling
school for a few months did you really
yeah
think about going to jamar neighbors has
me going to crown college idea
so i'm up to anything clown cos thinking
about it what is that
talk to me i don't know much about it
but he went he went jamar neighbors
jamar is so crazy yeah and so i was
talking to him about acting class
and he was like man i think you would
kill it at clown school
what the [ __ ] is clown school like what
do you do i especially there's a lot of
water bits
some prop work a lot of nose honking
yeah
but i bet you did some tumbling stuff
too so i'd be interested in that but
yeah wrestling school
tell me about pro wrestling school like
what
was this because you want to go full
david arquette
great reference never go full david
arkansas there's a you can't kill david
arquette
documentary yeah i know about it i just
watched the trailer for him like this
[ __ ] is killing himself like
this yeah he's out there doing
death matches getting hit in the head
with like light bulbs and [ __ ]
like okay yeah insane no i didn't want
to do that
um i just you know been a big fan of two
things my whole life comedy and pro
wrestling and
i decided i wanted to when i lost the
weight i was not aware of what my body
was capable of anymore
um you know i would still be like
pushing myself up
off of things and my trainer would be
like what the [ __ ] like you know you're
much
lighter than you think you are oh that's
funny and so i decided to go to habits
yeah old habits so i decided to go to
school to be like okay let me throw my
body around let me
do as many [ __ ] squats as i can let
me see what i can do oh did they make
you do like the bodyweight squats oh
yeah
like carl gotch type workouts oh yeah
one day they were just mad at us so they
made us do like 375 squats
oh that's a fun day the next day huh it
was it was a [ __ ] bathtub day
oh my god